am wochenende in berlin protest gegen
die korona politik der bundesregierung
ohne mundschutz ohne abstand
mehrere tausend polizisten sind im
einsatz auf der bühne auch ein polizist
er ruft seine kollegen zum widerstand
auf unsere polizeien des bundes und des
landes werden in unserem land keine
diktatur schulden und sie werden auch
keine diktatur durchsetzen
bei querdenken demos tritt er regelmäßig
auf karl hills polizeibeamter im
ruhestand einst hat er einen eid
geschworen auf den staat jetzt stellt er
sich gegen ihn dass diese kanzlerin und
die 16 ministerpräsidenten die diese
verbrechen begehen vor das kriegsgericht
gestellt und verurteilt werden
[Musik]
der ex polizist wird vom bayerischen
verfassungsschutz beobachtet wegen
demokratiefeindliche bestrebungen karl
hills bedroht repräsentanten des staates
gerade in ihrer funktion indem er immer
wieder auf demonstrationen dazu aufruft
diese personen für ein kriegsverbrecher
gericht zu stellen
er fordert seine ehemaligen kollegen
dazu auf unter berufung auf ein
angebliches widerstandsrecht sich gegen
den staat zu wenden hills sieht sich
nicht als verfassungsfeind er hat einen
verein gegründet polizisten für
aufklärung ist bundesweit aktiv
ich rufe meine kollegen meine 40 aktiven
kollegen dazu auf die grundrechte der
menschen zu schützen und sie schützend
zwischen die bevölkerung und die
diktatur zu stellen es ist kein putsch
erster akt des widerstands keine maske
tragen hills präsentiert uns ein
ärztliches attest das sind davon befreit
auf der demo wenige masken viele atteste
die polizei hilflos
es muss ärzte geben die so etwas
ausstellen einer von ihnen ist der arzt
rolf krohn menschen werden wir mit einen
stoß druck heraus geholt weil sie keine
maske tragen können weil sie
gesundheitliche probleme haben
kronhardt fake atteste ausgestellt ein
schulleiter hatte diesen verdacht in
einer mail bat er um die masken
befreiung meines sohnes otto wir möchten
dringend eine befreiung vom
maulkorbzwang für ihn bekommen und
bitten sie um ihre hilfe
der sohn otto war erfunden
doch trotzdem bekommt er post von der
praxis rolf krohn otto bekommt seiner
test dass das tragen einer mund nasen
bedeckung aufgrund nachfolgender
diagnosen nicht zumutbar oder möglich
ist atemnot panik kopfschmerzen
konzentrationsschwäche unterzeichnet von
rolf krohn
wir zeigen das attest dr broll vom
ärztlichen bezirksverband er ist
zuständig für die berufs aufsicht dieser
fall macht mich eigentlich sprachlos was
daher kronen macht es ist er stellt der
tester aus über personen die er nicht
kennt er stellt der tester aus die den
wissenschaftlichen grundlagen nicht erst
sprechen
er schlägt uns praktisch ins gesicht der
hand der ärzteschaft die sich an diese
regelungen halten und ihr verunsichert
natürlich wollen sie nicht damit
die staatsanwaltschaft augsburg
ermittelt gegen den arzt
es geht um rund 4.000 atteste die falsch
sein könnten nachfrage am rande der demo
wir haben den nachweis dass sie auch
attest ausgestellt haben
die es gar nicht gibt wer hat die
nachbarstaaten malzahn hat sie nicht
nein wir haben den wert auf welche
billig dass sich atteste ausgestellt für
patienten die es gar nicht gibt es
vorkommen dass es eben leute gibt er
namen erfinden und sagen mein sohn hat
massive beschwerden durch die maske
können sie uns helfen
und dann stand die einheit dann schreibe
ich ein attest ja weil ich ein
hilfsbereiter arzt rolf krohn ein arzt
der alles ablehnt was vor corona schützt
und jeder der seine ansichten teilt ist
ihm willkommen
ich war keine ahnung ob wir jetzt gleich
nach hause fährt und eure frauen oder
männer verprügelt ob ihr gewalttätigkeit
ob ihr euch kinderpornografisches
material anschaut oder ob ihr hitler
kreuze an die wände gemalt das ist mir
völlig schnuppe
ihr seid hier weil wir alle gemeinsam
hierfür eine sache stehen und das ist
für unsere freiheit und für unsere
zukunft kronhardt helfer und
unterstützer auch unter ärzten sie alle
hoffen auf eine große abrechnung was
ihrer prozesse 2 pohl geben und da
werden alle verurteilt werden die sowas
angeordnet haben finden sie es richtig
die pandemie und die bekämpfung der
pandemie mit dem nationalsozialismus
gleichzusetzen wenn sie sagen nur wenn
er prozesse 2.0 weltweit ist dass gerade
der dritte weltkrieg teer gefüllt wird
ja wohl nicht mehr passten genau sitzt
da es geht um die auslöschung der
menschheit menschheit daran haben sie
keine zweifel wir sind unterwegs in
bayern nach mühldorf am inn dort
praktiziert ein hausarzt der gerne
twittert dr rüdiger pusch facharzt für
allgemeinmedizin ehrenamtlicher
sozialrichter und delegiert hat so
landes ärztekammer dr pötsch twittert im
märz zur corona impfung schluss dem
genozid und der euthanasie dieses land
befindet sich im höllensturz der
verdammten
wir sind verabredet mit dem hausarzt mit
kassenzulassung dr pötsch ist davon
überzeugt durch die impfung soll die
weltbevölkerung dezimiert werden
es ist aufgrund der indizien die ich so
gibt nicht auszuschließen dass da ein
plan der geschickt getarnt ist dahinter
steckt aber soll der was soll der
bewertung und wer steckt dahinter
es ist ja geplant die nationen
aufzulösen sie zu durchmischen mit
anderen ethnien und schließlich eine
global ist ische welt zu bilden mit
einer weltregierung und seine
verschwörungs fantasien gehen noch
weiter dann ist es einer der größten
menschen versuche in der
medizingeschichte
die ich durchaus in der auswirkung mit
den verbrechen der erste schafft in der
nazizeit vergleichen kann
wir haben halt inzwischen mehr menschen
also gibt's noch mehr zwischenfälle und
noch mehr elend wenn ich daran denke
wenn damals ein herr doktor mengele
jungen männern alter informiert hat um
mal zu gucken was da passiert war eine
entsetzliche dinge die da vorgefallen
sind wirklich hat seine ämter bei der
ärztekammer niedergelegt als arzt
praktiziert er weiter der berufsverband
hilflos ich hoffe heute einfach auf die
staatsanwaltschaft denn es geht ja in
richtung volksverhetzung post läuft und
das ist halt auch straff bewirkt zurück
in berlin neben ärzten und polizisten
stehen auch soldaten auf der demo bühne
maximilian ein oberst der bundeswehr
ich rede also matthias der militärischen
perspektive über unsere grund unserer
als recht
jeder hat das kommando spezialkräfte ksk
mit aufgebaut eine elitetruppe ende der
90er führte er ein bataillon im kosovo
damals diente er seinem land heute ist
der oberst außer dienst überzeugt die
korona politik der bundesregierung muss
gestoppt werden und hier ordentlich
aufräumen dann könnte man sie muss sie
können wie soldaten ärzte und polizisten
einige nutzen ihre glaubwürdigkeit und
autorität um anzuheizen und aufzuwiegeln
stadt zu heilen und zu helfen
[Musik]